so Fox News's Sean Hannity suggested two
witnesses in the robert muller trump
russia investigation that they start
destroying evidence
and i guess it was sort of joking to
make a point about hillary clinton but
it's still a really dumb thing to say
and the backstory of this is that robert
muller recently asked witnesses to hand
over their phones so that investigators
could look at conversations that they
had had encrypted messaging and other
messaging data and sean hannity said on
his program before you give your stuff
to robert Muller's team delete
everything off of the hard drive or
phone and acid-wash them which he said
wednesday night on his program let's
take a look at the video i don't know if
i advise them to follow hillary
clinton's lead delete all your emails
and then acid-wash the emails and hard
drives on the new phones then take your
phones and bash them with a hammer into
little itsy-bitsy pieces use bleach bit
remove the SIM cards and then take the
pieces and hand it over to robert muller
and say Hillary Rodham Clinton Clinton
this is equal justice under the law how
do you think that would work out for
everybody who mo is demanding their
phones of tonight now I'm certain the
result would not be the same as
Hillary's right this is a crime
punishable by up to 20 years in prison
of course I get it he's doing it in a
sort of tongue-in-cheek way Sean Hannity
saying if Hillary got away with it why
not do it yourself and of course it's
ridiculous and it's actually not that
surprising to hear Sean Hannity give bad
legal advice since after all he at one
point sought out advice from Trump's
lawyer Michael Cohen and anybody who
thinks to get advice from Michael Cohen
is not somebody that I would be willing
to receive advice from yeah how's
Michael Cohen doing right now exact well
not particularly well and for everybody
who's just focusing on David it was just
a joke he wasn't being serious it was
really a point about how there's a
double standard over how Hillary Clinton
was treated but what about the big
picture that everybody's missing which
unless you have things to hide why would
you destroy evidence anyway right like
in other words whether or not Sean
Hannity is actually telling people to
destroy evidence before a federal
investigation or satirically making a
point about Hillary Clinton it's only
useful to destroy evidence
if their evidence if there is evidence
that would be incriminating which I
guess Sean Hannity is considering to be
a foregone conclusion here right the
question is whether he's joking about
destroying the evidence or not there
doesn't seem to be any question about
the reality that there is incriminating
evidence that people might be turning
over to Robert Moeller and if it's
simply a witch hunt and there are no
crimes that have been committed
nobody would feel the need to destroy
any evidence and that's been basically
missing from the reporting on this story
there's also another key word here okay
destruction of evidence is illegal under
federal law when you're being
investigated by an FBI special
prosecutor like Robert Muller Trump has
made it very clear he has signaled
clearly that he is going to be handing
out federal pardons like candy so why
not destroy the evidence and if you're
convicted of destroying evidence
Trump's just going to pardon you and
I've actually been thinking a lot about
this pardons strategy recently I guess
because Trump recently said he has the
right to pardoned himself I came to the
conclusion that the solution to the
pardoned Fiasco which is Trump could
possibly pardon people that get
convicted the solution is voting in
November and then voting in 2020 and
what I mean is if Trump's not president
he can't pardon people right this is an
investigation that could go on for a
long time
Trump has been saying it would end what
was it Pat like by Thanksgiving or of
last last year so still awaiting around
for the still waiting around for that
date which is in the past clearly this
is not ending soon and these
investigations this particular
investigation could go on long enough
that by the time the investigation is
over and the indictment start and if
there are actual convictions Trump could
be well out of power by that time
certainly if he is knocked out in 2020
even if he stays until 2024
these things can just take a very very
long time so vote in November to get
Republicans out of power in the house
and get them out of power in the Senate
vote in 2020 to get Donald Trump out and
then you don't have to worry about the
pardons strategy assuming of course that
the next president isn't as deranged as
Trump and is willing to just pardon
anybody convicted in the entire Trump
fiasco which would not be a historical
right I mean we have a history of
presidents pardoning prior presidents so
who was it that pardoned Nixon I think
it was Gerald Ford yeah so the best
thing you can do is just go out and vote
and I get it the pardon the pardon story
is disturbing because it's so depressing
to think that there's going to be years
of this stuff and political capital tied
up in it and taxpayer money correctly
tied up in it because there were
possible crimes committed and then that
Trump would just pardon his and
everybody else's way out of it I get it
that's really depressing this is going
to go on long enough that if we take
back the House and Senate in 2018 and
knock Trump out in 2020 he's not going
to be in power in order to do those
pardons yeah 2018 I'm certainly with you
I don't think the Robert Miller
investigation is going to wrap up by
then 2020 I mean that's the two and a
half years away so we'll see how long
this thing goes I get it like there
wouldn't be that sense of catharsis if
Trump and his cronies got in trouble
after they were out of power yeah in
order to really arrive at that sense of
justice that I think the public wants it
would have to involve him getting in
trouble getting impeached potentially
while he's present while he's president
I don't have no control over that I
don't disagree but I'm just thinking out
loud it doesn't really seem that the
Moller investigation is going to end
before the midterms so that gettest gets
us to November of 2018 let's say that it
goes on for another nine to twelve
months beyond that that gets us to
November of 2019 at which point possibly
all of the remaining indictments get
handed down that only leaves a year for
the indictment to be processed for the
trials to take place and for convictions
to be made
followed by possible sentencing a year's
not that much time for that stuff a lot
of these case
go on for multiple years so I actually
don't think it's that unrealistic to
think the trials could extend if there
were going to be any I'm not in a good
where I think there definitely will be
it could extend beyond the 2020 election
and all of that controversy could bring
out a trump resignation or at least a
statement that he's not going to seek
reelection because sure he would have no
chance and the country would be in total
turmoil at that point I got an email
from a viewer saying to go back to Sean
Hannity's joke about destroying evidence
the viewer says David don't you realize
that Hannity wants to be pulled into
Robert molars investigation and to be
interviewed he's been in touch with
Michael Cohen he speaks to Trump
reportedly several nights a week and I
actually think that it would be really
good for Sean Hannity's career the truth
is that if Sean Hannity can come out and
say on his radio show and on his TV show
he now is part of the witch-hunt and
because of his honest reporting about
Moeller
Muller is now targeting him it is
instantly a cash cow ratings boom for
Sean Hannity so I don't know that that's
what Hannity is thinking but I agree
with the viewer that it would be really
good for Hannity's business to be pulled
into Robert molars investigation that
would be interesting but if you play
with fire you can get burned and it
would be pretty tough I think for Sean
Hannity to remote into his show from
prison from a jail cell yeah that could
be pretty difficult send me your
thoughts about all of this was Hannity
joking or not do you think he broke the
law anyway even if he was joking there's
an article arguing that Hannity did
something illegal even by joking about
this and number three would Hannity
benefit from being pulled into the
Moller investigation I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Cody which is an innovative new
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that is setting out to
revolutionize how we send and receive
online payments the same way that the
transportation industry has been
innovated by ride-sharing apps the same
way that music and video distribution
have been revolutionized by real-time
streaming Cody says that the payment
industry is ripe for transfer
Meishan right now cody stands for
currency of the internet and they're
setting out to make their cryptocurrency
which was designed specifically to be
used for payments that will be the first
crypto if they succeed used on a
widespread mainstream basis for online
payments this will be payment system
that can be used by anyone whether
you're a consumer or a business and
regardless of the industry that you're
in most Kryptos fail to meet the
everyday needs of average consumers or
businesses and many crypto currencies
just weren't built with convenient and
trustworthy payment as their sort of
primary function and this is the
specific niche that Cody is trying to
fill with the technology that they've
created you're watching this on youtube
you can find out more about Cody and
their ICO in the links below the video
this is not financial advice and you
should do all of your own research
before making any investment decisions